let's have a look at each of these
questions okay so we'll start the top
now interestingly interestingly I see
there is three fifths plus two-thirds
okay and then we have a look at this
working here just for starters who
agrees with the final answer final
answer hands up straight ends up
straight straight so I can really see
okay make your hands down the vast
majority view which is fine we'll check
in the middle way to try first one but
but I think all of us can comment on how
we can improve not just the final answer
but the way we got there now you might
recall I just want to jog your memory I
talked to yesterday straight to use
their a lot about the equals sign and
what it means it means you've got
something to the left of an equal sign
and something to the right of an equal
sign you're saying they are identical
equal right now what should have a look
have a look at the very first equal sign
that has been written the very first
equal sign that's been written this one
here right at least two critical is it
the same to say a fraction plus another
fraction is this fraction times another
number now I have no problem with
multiplying things and all that kind of
thing in order to make things simpler
but but this is here and this here are
two completely different things
completely different right I'm not only
that I see what's going on can someone
explain to me what does this x 3 what is
the reason why it's there not not what's
it doing but why is there doing very
good so I can see thought process I see
what's going on oh i need to multiply
this one by three on three and this one
my five on five right which does get
done separate okay but is that what this
means is that how would I write it
instead to convey what's going on a true
sailor
yeah so this this plus sign it
disappears and then it reappears okay so
I see what's going on in your brain no I
can't want to do this part of the
problem first and then I'll do that part
of the problem and there's no I have no
problems with that that's really good
you're breaking you down to manageable
chunks but you don't want like one of
the choices disappear and then suddenly
turn okay um we want it all to be there
if you're really saying it's equal oh
there's one more thing i would add
notice here when they multiply by three
the three other times become a nine cool
this five turned into a 15 how did that
happen yeah Rihanna yes so in fact I've
not only multiplied the numerator by 3
i've also multiplied the denominator so
what's really happened is a x 3 on three
of course you have to because otherwise
we'd be changing the number right three
on three is ok because what is three on
three 3/3 3/3 is just one so it doesn't
change the number you can multiply
something by one as many times as you
like and it's still the same normal does
that make sense ok so having addressed
that but you know we don't want numbers
to appear and then sorry disappear then
reappear and also making sure when you
change the denominator you're changing
the whole number so right the whole
fraction I think one on 14 1 and 4 15
looks pretty good I'm happy with that ok
so give that a thing if you got them all
right let's have a look at this guy over
here so having a look at them the first
line of working can someone describe for
me in words what is this step we have we
have language to describe what's going
on here what is this person done this
place is me ok so someone else I want
someone else to be able just working and
tell me what's happening someone anyone
does
okay we're simplifying it that's very
good in what particular way are we
simplified yeah I know you know the
answer because you wrote it down see
this is important right you might know
what you're doing but if you can't
communicate to someone else so they can
see what's going on that is we need
better than okay Hayden yeah he's
basically undivided the 16 x 4 and 15 55
yep so you get the UH 3 over 4 and sorry
I'm so you go 1 over 1 times yep
sleeping with three buddies okay
excellent so that division right another
word we use for this is called canceling
because you can see for instance just
over here this is for right and sixteen
is four times for to the other for the
time and before at the bottom so i can
cancel them right and that's exactly
what he's done cancel cancel leaving
with the for you see you see does that
make sense it's really important you not
just be able to do it but you can
articulate you could recognize this one
else other ok now this very last one
okay I'm not gonna look too much of the
working just yet all I'm going to
suggest is this something that caused me
into the bag the discount I'd be right
now can so I tell me cuz on articulate
what he meant what what he meant was 12
/ 36 ah sir so if ye meant was that then
that should be written here right so
there's an issue of communication right
and what was met versus what is there ok
now just poison for saying it I if I see
this how do I know if I did this working
and I thought this is my final wine how
do I know something's gone wrong someone
tell me how do I know something is gone
what do you any doesn't
okay that's true like just speaking
about this in a simple our fee that's
that's very fair you can think about
this as well this is like a number
around one just estimate just that's me
another round one and number around to
you multiply them 36 is a huge number
right it's a huge number okay so hands
down let me show you how i would do this
and then you can tell me where the error
has crept in okay first thing you're
going to do is just like here I'm gonna
get out of mixed new moves okay so could
somebody tell me what this is is a mix
in your mouth yeah 43 and this as a
mixed dear Mum someone have it yeah 3 4
very good so you can see now oh look
just like before I can cancel is a four
and A four can I cancel here I can't cut
I if I divide this by three and this by
three these guys no one does it seem
like it's more of the ballpark that
seems result you yeah it works out ok so
36 divided by 12 would have got a stare
but there was some promising where did
the error creep in by the way can
someone tell me where the aircraft is
hot on a post line 1 1 2 3 4 weird or 45
which line so on some other just as a
safety freak one of you is it was your
line for landfill by line for something
has definitely gone wrong but it's
before that the error actually occurred
Silas yeah in a three line 3 while I'd 3
what's gone wrong in life because
Boyd armies accidentally I did he made
the denominator equal the same yep Mike
and the fighting um and so and so he got
too much of a number so that's why I
ended up yeah yeah very good so the
numbers of all inflated interestingly
he's actually not like from here to here
he's converted he didn't need to we
converted here because you are adding
them together right but for
multiplication their conversion is
necessary so this wasn't required but at
least what I'm looking at it now it's
not wrong it's not wrong it's actually
easy transitions from line three to live
for okay 16 x 27 I don't know if you dis
actually accurate I think it is 432 but
look 12 x 12 because you have to do top
and the bottom 12 is not 12 what is
taught x 12 it's Hydra 44 square I was a
pretty good third so this should really
be 144 that's why this should be fun by
12 and that's what we gave you three
okay so it's not just important to be
able to get a right answer or see what's
going on you have to be able to like I
make mistakes all the time I wouldn't be
able to fix my mistakes that's really
important to me okay not just say oh I
got it wrong it's over does that make
sense